so first up
we're adding our olive oil to the pan so
drew you're gonna do around two
tablespoons and you're gonna swirl it
around and make sure that gets
nice and warmed up and i'm gonna adjust
my heat a little bit down yeah turn it
down a little bit and the medium heat
yeah medium to high i think and then
you're gonna add your chili flakes
and your sliced garlic so give that a
good swirl
and that's gonna go for about 30 seconds
to 45 seconds and you don't want to
you're not burning the garlic you're
basically having the garlic perfume the
oil
perfume and it's basically as soon as
the garlic kind of starts to get a
little sticky you're going to see it
like go a little translucent that's when
you know you're going to pull it out but
in the meantime drew you have some
peeled
uh and deveined and cleaned head-on
shrimp parked right beside you i do
right here and we're just going to
season one side of the shrimp so these
are head-on if people don't want to do
heads on you can totally do a larger
shrimp head off just make sure that
they're peeled i love a head-on shrimp
i think it has a lot more flavor and
it's a lot more fun to eat with my hands
so drew i fished out with your little
slotted spatula
your garlic so it doesn't burn i hate
burnt garlic i really do it just makes
me mad and it makes me feel like a
culinary failure and we're going to come
back to the garlic shortly
so now your pan is clean that slotted
spoon is you want one of these in your
kitchen it's a game changer we're laying
down the shrimp all right here we go all
right and you want that shrimp
lay it down the seasoned side down first
and then when they're all in the pan
there's that good sizzle i have a little
bit of a wet towel i'm going to wipe my
hand
shake it around and then you're going to
season the second side and the reason
why i don't want to do both sides at the
same time is because i don't want to
keep handling my shrimp the heads on
tend to pop off occasionally and i'm
really trying my best
to keep them on i'm not gonna lie i've
never made this dish without my heads
rolling we're gonna see i think
because i'm not delicate about anything
i'm just not i'm a rough i i'm i'm
sensitive and gentle and loving but i
like
i'm a i'm a rough and tumbler you're
doing great there though
spicy
all right so i'm gonna peek on the other
side and the great thing about shellfish
is that it's gonna tell you when it's
cooked it's gonna change color as you
can see here it starts to change color
pink and then it's gonna have a little
bit of um
spots and like caramelization so i'm
just taking this little spatula tool a
palette knife and flipping them over
look at that look at how gorgeous
i just made that
and trust me if i can do it
you can do it because i'm not a culinary
snob i was about to take culinary slob
actually i have a culinary slump but i'm
not a culinary snob and i want to
encourage people to get out of their
fear and get into their comfort zone all
right drew add your packs of butter
we're going to do two tablespoons i'm
moving on
and then you're gonna put
i have a third of a cup of white wine
and drew you have a non-alcoholic
substitute i do because i don't drink
alcohol and sometimes it doesn't cook
down enough
and then i get that taste and it's like
that's not what i want yeah but i will
serve you a glass of wine i just don't
want to cook with it so i'm doing um
water and apple cider vinegar that's the
trick yep
and then i'm throwing in
that garlic that i rescued earlier
that you rescued i rescued it that
garlic in distress
and then i'm going to squeeze half a
lemon
into the sauce i'm going to save the
other half of the lemon because i'm
going to taste the sauce a little later
it might not need it but it might it
might it's the same prepared you've got
a backup plan so that's just cooking and
basically what you're looking for with
the shrimp is for all of it to be
completely the same color like that nice
pink rosiness
and to the touch it's going to be
slightly firm so a raw shrimp is going
to feel a little have more give and be
more soft and this one is going to be
nice and firm and i think we're almost
there my shrimp is pretty much cooked
drew how are you doing over there my
shrimp is cooked all right so all you're
gonna do actually is remove the shrimp
you're gonna keep that sauce going
remove the shrimp
lovely remove it with love and care love
and care hey drew you have all your
heads on can you believe it it's the
first
there's a first for everything man
today i was like today's the day pilar
that i am not going to botch this
sometimes you just wake up on the i'm
not going to lose
my head's side of the bed
if you know what i mean
so i'm going to give my sauce a quick
taste i think it needs to reduce a
little bit mine's i don't want mine to
reduce anymore i don't think because
mine's like really that's delicious i'm
going to do a little bit of salt
mine needs a little salt too yup
all right and then
two finishing actions you pour that
beautiful sauce
all over the scampi
this is also where i wish i had a little
bit of a silicone
um spatula yeah because then you can
really get and scrape every little juicy
bit out of there absolutely don't miss
anything
and then we just finish it off
with some chopped parsley garnish makes
all the difference it really does
you ready
look at that
[Music]